well in recent years the left's moral
voices that would be of course madonna
jennifer lopez leonardo dicaprio people
who couldn't find their way unaided to
el segundo have discovered the amazon
rainforest where it turns out fires
sometimes break out they say the amazon
rainforest is being destroyed not by
clear cutting committed by china no
criticizing china is racist
but because of bolsonaro or something
anyway the earth is in the balance
we asked bolsonaro about that
is the
amazon
being destroyed at the rate that we read
that it is no
no have you had a deal with no that is
not true
two-thirds of the brazilian territory
are currently preserved and remain
pristine just as they were back in the
1500s when this country was discovered
by the portuguese
the criminal acts that do happen
we will not deny that
ultimately given too much visibility
because there is a huge interest in
making our sovereignty over the
amazonian region a relative fact or
perceived in a relative light
i met with president putin and thanked
him because on two occasions when this
issue was discussed with other countries
he stated that the amazon region belongs
to the brazilian people
not to anyone else
the amazon region is as vast as eastern
europe
it's huge it's wonderful
it's just not possible to you know take
care of every square meter in the amazon
region
there is illegal deforestation yes there
are fire outbreaks yes
but not at the rate that is announced
out there
california itself always you know
catches fire
and it's not given that much visibility
french guyana likewise i mean you can't
possibly set a rainforest to fire but
there is illegal deforestation yes
and we are working to tackle that and
how can we solve the issue
well it depends on the brazilian
parliament
it depends on land regularization
we need the legislation to be passed to
that effect in the future any heat focus
directed by a satellite will point to
the ultimate owner of that land
where you seem to have a focus of fire
or a fire outbreak beginning
you will be able to know whether it
belongs to the federal administration or
to a private owner or to the riverside
people
sometimes the riverside populations set
fields of fire for agricultural or
cropping purposes
and that technology will certainly help
us prevent any kind of deforestation
i mean the amazon region is as vast as
eastern europe
it is not easy to take care of
the
indigenous reserve itself is as big as
twice the territory of the state of rio
de janeiro
which is a big state
so with technology
we will certainly be able to preserve
the amazonian region we do not depend on
international interest in preserving the
amazonian region
it is our own interests and we of course
want these preservation efforts to be
somehow reciprocated by means of carbon
credits
you are opposed by
most actors
in brazil and celebrities
models
tv presenters and we learned recently
that mark ruffalo
also doesn't like you
you don't seem bothered at all by this
why
so
if i do bother or become concerned about
all of the criticism i get
i would not be able to work
of course no one likes to be criticized
these are people who do not understand
anything about brazil
i think these people have never been to
the amazon region and i would actually
invite them to come to the amazon region
and overfly the region
and they will see an outstanding region
they will be able to overfly it you will
see no fire outbreak you will not see
the devastated areas
i mean they talk about the amazon region
because it's trendy it's a fad
i mean in europe
if someone says that the amazon region
is not being devastated
they are politically doomed to fiasco
so it's politically good for them
you know the criticism yields power
yields media visibility
yields votes and that's what celebrities
feed on
they're not at all familiar with the
amazon region
they are not at all knowledgeable about
the region
and the difficulty of investing in it
they just criticize it because it's a
fad
so you don't seem that bothered by mark
ruffalo's dislike of you have you
enjoyed being president of brazil
i must admit you know i first launched
myself as a candidate of course i
intended to become the president
but i was all too aware of the
challenges and difficulties
and the experiences we have undergone or
i have undergone
i could never ever have imagined what it
would look like
but i am comforted by the fact that the
other candidate the workers party
candidate
haddad
if he had one brazil would certainly be
what venezuela is today
so that's a source of comfort to me and
that encourages me to say to the
population that god is the one who has
placed me
where i am today mr president thank you
for having us you're welcome a message
to the americans god the homeland family
and freedom
thank you so much
the main reason we came to brazil was to
report on what china is doing something
that's being ignored on purpose in the
united states
china is working hard to turn the
developing world into a new colony a
colony of china that's particularly true
in brazil the country with the richest
natural resources in the region brazil a
military beachhead for china
it's of concern we asked bolsonaro about
that and what he's doing to stop it next
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight